well we do have Karissa in the studio
with us Karissa first of all
congratulations a big victory with the
white pieces against the defending
Champion uh first of all take us through
the game and how do you feel after this
important
Victory um yeah I felt it was a pretty
clean game overall felt good about my
play um I think from start to finish I
just felt that I was doing pretty well
and I knew that I was probably much
better after I got in uh night A5 night
A5 that was the key uh situation but
before that did you expect her to play
the
caroan no the caroan was a total
surprise I was expecting um E5 on move
one and so yeah I think I've been
playing Jennifer since like 2015 or
something probably even earlier for
almost 10 years now and she's never uh
pulled out the car against me so I
thought it was surprising but um I think
I handled the surprise pretty well not a
bad surprise because you definitely got
the advantage out of the opening and it
felt like you knew the positions uh
better how to handle the positions how
to open them up with the move C4
following it up with Knight to A5 so a
great game by you you're one of the
players that's coming back from Mexico
where you participated in the world
juniors you actually took the silver
medal in that one now there's always
this debate look you had a lot of time
to prepare during that tournament you're
coming with a luggage of opening
theoretical ideas but also in terms of
your energy levels perhaps you know
they're a little bit sa how do you feel
right
now yeah I feel pretty good I will say
at the end of world juniors that was
also 11 round
tournament um I was feeling a little
done with chess uh but
uh but that's kind of worn off now I
feel good I feel like it was a bit of a
sort of warmup for this event and yeah I
feel like I kind of got the nerves out
of the way there and so I can show my
best chust now but one question between
the world juniors and the USA
championships you're missing one month
of school at Stanford that's not easy
are you still doing homework in between
games what's uh what's the plan
there yeah definitely
um so I'm missing the first three weeks
cuz Stanford starts a bit later than
other schools and I've been sort of
keeping up with lectures and homeworks
online and remotely so seems to be going
okay so far but hopefully I can keep
that up challenge guys any questions uh
just our congratulations uh Karissa keep
it up you've got a lot of games ahead of
you thank you absolutely absolutely and
as we're going to take a a break